[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
Willkommen an diesem zweiten Advent
Norbert König ist auch dabei mit Fußball
und Wintersport guten Abend und das sind
unsere Themen
Ankündigung in Teheran gut zwei Monate
nach dem Beginn der Proteste soll das
mula-regime die berüchtigte
Sittenpolizei aufgelöst haben
ein Zeichen für die Völkerverständigung
die russische Menschenrechtlerin Irina
scherbakova wird mit dem Marion dönhoff-
und der Titelverteidiger gewinnt
Weltmeister Frankreich schlägt Polen und
zieht ins WM-Viertelfinale ein
[Applaus]
wir beginnen mit den überraschenden
Nachrichten aus ihrer an seit elf Wochen
gibt es dort Massenproteste Frauen gehen
ohne Kopftuch auf die Straße es kommt
immer wieder zu blutigen
Auseinandersetzungen hunderte starben
und jetzt die unerwartete Ankündigung
des Generalstaatsanwalts er sagt die
berüchtigte Sittenpolizei sei
abgeschafft Jörg Brase hat mir
Frauen werden festgenommen und den
kleinen Busse oder Polizeifahrzeuge
gezerrt beim Einsatz der Sittenpolizei
werden die islamischen
Kleidervorschriften auch mit brutaler
Härte durchgesetzt seit Mitte der 80er
Jahre gibt es die Moralwächter die
zuletzt im Innenministerium unterstellt
waren sie sollten Frauen im richtigen
tragen dass sie Job unterweisen doch
seitdem Tod massaminis die nach einem
Einsatz der Sittenwächter starb war die
Polizeitruppe umstritten nun äußerte
sich Irans Generalstaatsanwalt indirekt
zu deren Auflösung die Sittenpolizei hat
nichts mit der Judikative zu tun sondern
sie wurde von der Stelle die Sie
eingerichtet hat abgeschafft
eine offizielle Bestätigung des
Innenministeriums über die Auflösung der
Sittenpolizei gibt es nicht angeblich so
montesserie soll auch über eine Reform
der Kopftuch Regeln diskutiert werden
eine Diskussion die es ebenfalls seit
einiger Zeit im iranischen Parlament
gibt
es ist unwahrscheinlich dass das
Kopftuch komplett abgeschafft wird aber
es könnte Änderungen geben wie mit dem
Kopftuch Gebot umgegangen wird
bei einem Krisentreffen soll die
Regierung und Präsident reissi heute
über die jüngsten Entwicklungen
diskutiert haben für morgen hat die
Opposition zu landesweiten Protesten
aufgerufen
[Musik]
fragen wir unseren Korrespondenten Jörg
Brase wie kommt diese angebliche
Abschaffung der Sittenpolizei an bei den
Iranern und Iranerinnen
also die Reaktion hier die waren doch
eher sehr verhalten in Iran einige
Iranerinnen mit denen wir heute sprechen
konnten die sagen uns dass sie nun auch
bei einer möglichen Auflösung der
Sittenpolizei nicht damit rechnen dass
die Kontrollen und nun auch die Strafen
enden würden Sie sagen uns dass das
Kopftuch und auch die Sittenpolizei
eigentlich nur zwei Probleme von vielen
seinen mit denen sie zu kämpfen hätten
darum geht es Ihnen gar nicht zuvor dass
ihnen geht es vor allem um weiterhin
einen regime-wechsel in der Islamischen
Republik sie halten diese Ankündigung
auch eher für ein Ablenkungsmanöver der
Regierung für den Versuch der
Protestbewegung den Wind aus den Segeln
zu nehmen und auch andere gesprächsannte
Gebote der Regierung lassen sie ja
unbeeindruckt und so haben dann einige
Oppositionsgruppen daneben auch für
morgen zu dreitägigen landesweiten
Protesten und Streiks aufgerufen
danke für diese Einschätzung Jörg Brase
danke nach Istanbul
auch in Russland ist es lebensgefährlich
sich öffentlich für Menschenrechte
einzusetzen Irina schabakova floh im
März mit ihrem Mann aus Moskau seither
kämpft die Mitbegründerin der
Menschenrechtsorganisation Memorial aus
Deutschland und Israel weiter in Hamburg
wurde die 73-Jährige Historikerin heute
mit dem Marion dönhoff-preis
ausgezeichnet die Laudatio hielt der
Bundeskanzler Steffen Wachs und
Christian sem
die tiefe Überzeugung ihr Land zum
Besseren zu verändern habe sie als
Historikerin und Menschenrechtlerin
immer angetrieben erzählt Irina
scherbakova bei der Preisverleihung
dieser Preis ist natürlich eine sehr
große eine unglaublich Anerkennung und
also unserer Arbeit in Memorial weil
hinter mir und das wurde hier ja schon
gesagt also stehen Jahre und sehr sehr
viele Menschen Bundeskanzler Scholz
würdigt scherberkoffer für ihren mutigen
Kampf für die mittlerweile in Russland
verbotene Menschenrechtsorganisation
Memorial sie halten den Preis auch
stellvertretend für all diejenigen
Russen die sich eine andere bessere
hellere
Zukunft Auslands vorstellen können
gegründet 1989 arbeitete Memorial vor
allem die Gräueltaten des stalinterrors
auf und pflegt bis heute
listenpolitischer Gefangener auf der
auch Kremlkritiker Alexander valny steht
seit einem Jahr ist Memorial verboten
der Vorwurf die Organisation habe sich
als sogenannter ausländischer Agent
nicht dann Auflagen gehalten und 200
kremlkritische Organisationen Medien und
Personen sind als ausländische Agenten
gebrandmarkt Straßen drohen wer die
wachsweich formulierten Auflagen nicht
erfüllt auch die
flüchtlingshilfsorganisation von
Svetlana ganoschkina in Moskau steht auf
dieser Liste
all diese Gesetze beweisen nur eins die
Schwäche der Staatsmacht sie geht
vielleicht hart und grausam vor aber sie
ist schwach denn sie begreift dass sie
im Unrecht ist das ausländische
agentengesetz wurde jetzt noch mal
verschärft jeder Kontakt zu einem
Ausländer kann bestraft werden Memorial
macht trotz des Verbots weiter in off
schnell und im Ausland die
Menschenrechtler sagen Memorial sei eine
Mentalität miteinander verbundener
Staatsbürger diese zu zerstören sei
unmöglich
haltet durch so der Appell der
ukrainischen Behörden an die Bevölkerung
nach den massiven russischen Angriffen
auf das Stromnetz haben viele Haushalte
weiterhin nur zeitweise oder gar keinen
Strom und das bei Temperaturen unter
Null was der Winter für die Menschen und
für den Fortgang des Krieges bedeutet
zeigt Alexandra Vacano
von inners Haus ist nicht mehr viel
übrig die Ruinen Schnee bedeckt in
diesem ersten kalten Kriegswinter
es ist schwer für alle ich will mein
Haus ich möchte in Frieden leben aber
das ist doch kein Leben
es ist ein Leben ohne Wasser und immer
wieder ohne Strom nicht nur hier für die
verbliebenen in kalinifka 250 km
entfernt von Kiew sondern auch in mehr
als 500 weiteren Orten laut ukrainische
Regierung in diesem Zelt in herson
finden die Menschen was Sie brauchen
etwas Wärme und endlich Strom um
wenigstens das Handy aufzuladen in der
Nacht gab es bei Ihnen wieder Angriffe
auf Stromleitungen Häuser ihre Stadt
eigentlich von den russischen Besatzern
befreit wird weiterhin von ihnen
attackiert sie hätten sich in den Kampf
verbissen rund um die Stadt bachmut in
der Region Don jetzt mit etwa 70.000
Einwohnern so britische Militärexperten
aber im Krieg sei das Tempo
zurückgegangen meinen US-Geheimdienste
und es könnte sich im Verlauf des
Winters weiter verlangsamen um sich neu
aufzustellen
wenn der Winter vorbei ist ist die Frage
wie die Gegenoffensive im Frühjahr
aussehen könnte wir sind skeptisch ob
die Russen für neue Kämpfe gerüstet sind
oder nicht mit Blick auf die Ukraine bin
ich optimistischer was diesen Zeitraum
angeht
trotz der Angriffe wie hier in razon und
trotz des harten Winters ist das Motto
der Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer
durchhalten
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck ist auf dem
Weg in südliche Afrika wieder um die
Energiewende voranzubringen Namibia gilt
als potentieller Partner für grünen
Wasserstoff dort muss ich der
Vizekanzler aber auch mit der deutschen
Kolonialgeschichte auseinandersetzen in
Südafrika sollen die
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen vertieft werden
nach den Protesten gegen die
anti-corona-maßnahmen in China rücken
immer mehr Regionen dort von ihrer
harten nullcovid-politik ab nach Peking
nun auch Shanghai wer bislang in den
Metropolen beispielsweise Busfahren oder
in einen Park gehen wollte brauchte
dafür einen corona-test ab morgen soll
das entfallen auch die
quarantänevorschriften werden im ersten
Regionen gelockert wenn auch nur leicht
heute feiert eine Institution Geburtstag
deren Bedeutung vielen gar nicht so
recht bewusst ist der Europäische
Gerichtshof sein Anspruch Gerechtigkeit
für fast 450 Millionen Menschen daran
arbeiten die Richter und Richterinnen
des EuGH jetzt seit genau 70 Jahren oft
geht es dabei auch um ganz alltägliches
unter welchen Umständen darf ein
Arbeitgeber das Tragen eines Kopftuchs
verbieten was müssen Online-Käufer bei
der Rückgabe einer Matratze beachten und
in Deutschland wird es keine Pkw-Maut
geben alles entschieden von ihm dem
mächtigsten Gericht Europas
der Europäische Gerichtshof hat in den
letzten 70 Jahren eine ganz bedeutende
Stellung erreicht er versteht sich als
Anwalt der Bürgerinnen und Bürger er
will versuchen dass das Recht der
Europäischen Union auch im Interesse der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger überall
durchgesetzt wird
gestartet ist er damit heute vor 70
Jahren damals waren es nur sieben
Richter und ein paar Übersetzer heute
arbeiten hier mehr als 2.200 Menschen
mehr als 600 sind allein damit
beschäftigt zu übersetzen der
Gerichtshof wächst und wächst und auch
sein Einfluss das gefällt nicht jeder so
stellte vor einem Jahr der polnische
Verfassungsgerichtshof den Vorrang des
EU-Rechts generell in Frage
die EU-Organe überschreiten ihre
Kompetenzen
und die polnische Republik kann nicht
demokratisch und souverän agieren
mit dieser Entscheidung Griff Polen die
Autorität des Gerichts direkt an
nicht der einzige Angriff in den
vergangenen Jahren auf den Vorrang des
EU-Rechts und damit auch auf die Macht
des Europäischen Gerichtshofs aber die
Geschichte hat gezeigt dass der
Europäische Gerichtshof sich am Ende
immer durchgesetzt hat dafür ist er aber
darauf angewiesen dass die
Mitgliedstaaten seine Entscheidung
respektieren und ihnen deshalb auch
Folgen genau darauf wird es auch
weiterhin 70 Jahre nach Gründung
ankommen damit die EU eine
Rechtsgemeinschaft bleibt
genau ein Jahr ist es her dass der
Vulkan Semeru auf der indonesischen
Insel Java ausbrach jetzt spuckt er
wieder gewaltige Aschewolken und Lava
und versetzt die Anwohner in Angst und
Schrecken viele fliehen aus ihren
Dörfern aus Sorge vor giftigen Dämpfen
dem neuen Vulkanausbruch war ein
Erdbeben vorausgegangen beim letzten
Ausbruch vor einem Jahr waren mehr als
50 Menschen gestorben 10.000 mussten
ihre Häuser verlassen
jetzt Fußball-WM Norbert
Titelverteidiger Frankreich scheint
ziemlich gut in Form deswegen wird der
Weltmeister auch zu den Top Favoriten im
Moment das Team ist der Star aber einer
ragt dann doch heraus Kilian mbappé von
Paris St Germain liefert eine brilliante
Vorstellung und ist an allen Treffern
beteiligt beim überlegenen 3:1-erfolg
gegen das Team aus Polen
der Favorit feiert erwartungsgemäß aber
zunächst Außenseiter Polen überraschend
stark Zielinski mit der Doppelchance und
Kaminskis Nachschuss auf der Linie
geklärt Frankreich unter Druck aber der
Titelverteidiger findet Offensive
Lösungen mbappé auf girou 1:0 in der 44
Minute Olivier girou jetzt mit 52
länderspieltreffern Rekord Torschütze
für Frankreich nach dem Wechsel deutlich
überlegen Dembele auf mbappé der legt
sich den Ball zurecht und trifft 2:0 in
der 74 Minute
Superstar mbappé mit ausgefeilter
Schusstechnik und die Beweis der kurz
vor Schluss erneut nicht zu stoppen
Kilian mbappé zum 3:0 Polen bekommt in
der Nachspielzeit noch einen
Handelfmeter zugesprochen den Robert
Lewandowski verwandelt 3:1 der Endstand
Frankreich im Viertelfinale Gegner dort
England oder Senegal
top-wochenende für Georg Hackl den neuen
techniktrainer des österreichischen
rodelteams seine Schützlinge gewinnen
alle acht Weltcup-Rennen in Innsbruck
Igels Deutschlands vorzeigerodler Felix
Loch stürzt im zweiten Lauf und kommt
mit einer Oberschenkelprellung davon
beim Doppelerfolg der österreichischen
Männer
pop-pilotin kim kalicki hat mit
Bremserin Leonie Fiebig das
zweierbob-rennen in Park City gewonnen
vor dem kolleginnen-team Nolte Neudecker
und auf Francesco Friedrich war wieder
der Schnellste
die typische Geste von Francesco
Friedrich nach seinem insgesamt 70 Sieg
im Weltcup im Viererbob ist es für den
Rekordweltmeister auf der Olympiabahn
von 2002 in Park City aber der erste
Erfolg trotz eines trainingssturzes
fährt der heute wieder eine der
Ideallinie durch den Eiskanal und
verweist seine Teamkollegen Johannes
Lochner und Christoph Hafer auf die
Plätze 2 und 3 für Snowboarder Martin
nörd hätte der Weltcup-Auftakt nicht
besser laufen können beim Snowboard
crossing LED Salz setzt sich der
Gesamtweltcup-Sieger des vergangenen
Winters bei schwierigen Bedingungen
souverän durch für nearl ist das der
insgesamt fünfte Weltcup Sieg der
Karriere vor dem Olympia dritten Oma wir
sind Tina aus Italien und dem
Silbermedaillengewinner
Elliot Condor aus Kanada
ich sagen schlechte Sicht gutes Ergebnis
bei uns wird es nicht so viel besser in
einem Streifen vom Rhein-Main-Gebiet bis
in die Lausitz bleibt es meist trocken
sonst regnet oder schneit es häufig im
Norden liegt die Schneefallgrenze bei
300 im Süden bei 700 Metern die
Temperatur steigt auf ein bis sieben
Grad im heute journal um 9:45 Uhr
spricht Christian Sievers mit dem
Präsidenten des Europäischen
Gerichtshofs hier übernimmt morgen mit
Sirin das gesamte heute Team sagt danke
und tschüss und wünscht Ihnen einen
guten Start in die neue Woche auf bald
[Musik]